If you don't know anything about medieval
art, you might reasonably assume old
illustrated texts featured basic depictions of
historical and religious figures. But medieval
art is overflowing with absurdity: particularly
when it comes to depictions of medieval beasts.
Beyond the dragons and unicorns you might
be familiar with is a truly insane world of
lesser-known monsters which stretched the
imagination with their utter bizarreness.
So today we're going to take a look at
the top 10 strangest of these creatures:
bearing in mind it was exceedingly
difficult to cut this down to just 10.
Number 10: monopod. Mythological creatures with
a single leg ending in a massive foot, monopod's
name comes from a Greek term aptly meaning
"one-foot." Medieval artists often drew them
lying down, with their foot stretched over their
head. This comes from a legend that the monopods
have a habit of protecting themselves from the sun
using the shade cast by their foot, sort of like
a natural umbrella. Number nine: bonnacon Though
at first glance these mythic creatures resemble
ordinary bulls, the bonnacon was said to eject
large amounts of caustic excrement at hunters.
While medieval texts often communicated
moral lessons through fictitious beasts,
the banaycon seems to have no symbolic meaning
whatsoever. If anything, it only shows lowbrow
humor hasn't changed much over the centuries.
Number eight: sea monk Ducking just slightly out
of the medieval period for a creature I had to
include, the sea monk is an organism allegedly
captured off the Danish coast which outwardly
resembled a monk in a habit. Supposedly, the
account claimed the animal's resemblance to a monk
was just a coincidence. The creature had the inner
workings of an ordinary fish, and just happened
to superficially resemble a monk on the outside.
Number 7: salamander This next one might seem like
an odd inclusion, since the amphibious salamander
isn't mythical at all. But medieval legends of
salamanders were, let's say, a little off from
the real-life organism. Alchemists believes
salamanders were fireproof, which is strange
enough, but many depictions of salamanders deviate
wildly from their actual appearance. Why so many
medieval artists assigned hair and human faces to
salamanders is, unfortunately, largely unclear.
Number 6: amphisbien Getting its name from
the greek term amphis, meaning "both ways,"
and bien, meaning "to go" this rather amusing
monster was a serpent with two opposing heads.
According to legend the unfortunate
reptile had difficulty moving around
due to the dual minds tugging
it in different directions.
Number 5 Shurale The only creature on this list
originating in Russia, Shurale is a long-fingered
humanoid from folk tales who dwells in the woods.
Though not too far off from trolls or goblins,
what makes Shurale so unusual is its behavior
according to legends, shirali lures the unlucky
into thickets where he... tickles them to death.
Something about that is genuinely unsettling.
Number four: snails One of my personal favorites:
like the salamander, medieval snails are based on
their real-life counterparts, but deviate
wildly from what you'd find in nature.
Manuscripts portray snails as enormous
weapon-wielding juggernauts, menacing knights
and helpless villagers. Hilariously, historians
aren't entirely sure why so many margins of
medieval texts feature these super-sized mollusks:
with theories ranging from political propaganda,
to the snails representing the slow but
inevitable approach of death which awaits us all.
Number three: Blemmyes. Headless creatures
with faces on their chests, the intelligent
and communal Blemmyes are another one of my
favorites. More so than the other entries
on this list, medieval European scholars believe
the Blemmyes to be more than the stuff of fables.
Many believed the Blemmyes were a real species
of humanoid living in other parts of the world,
to the point where they're featured on
several maps... just sort of hanging out.
Number two: the vegetable lamb of Tartary We're
really in the strange stuff now. The vegetable
lamb is a legendary plant which sprouted
fruit identical in appearance to sheep.
The sheep even contained blood and bones, despite
being plants. Holy Roman Empire historian Sigmund
Von Herbertstien even went as far as to say he'd
heard from too many credible sources to doubt
the plant's existence. Although Herbertstein was
obviously mistaken, modern scholars actually have
a theory that the legends origin stems from widely
circulated misinterpretations of cotton plants.
Pretty interesting stuff. Number one: Gryllus
I simply couldn't resist putting this little
guy at the very top. What you see is what you get
with this one: a pair of legs topped with a head,
parading in packs around the margins of
medieval manuscripts. They're simple,
but there's something so fundamentally absurd
about the Gryllus: especially considering their
origin is almost completely unknown. What
an incredible, albeit inexplicable creation.
And that's where our list comes to an end. I hope
you had fun going on this journey through the
bizarre world of medieval monsters with me. Please
consider subscribing, and leaving this video a
like if you enjoyed the content. Thank you so much
for watching, and I'll see you in the next video.